a Colorado woman on vacation in Las
Vegas was shot and killed last week
thanks for joining us at 11 I'm Denise
Valdez and I'm Brian Loftis police say
43-year-old Shauna McCowan was walking
into Southern Highlands neighborhood
last week when someone drove up and
randomly shot and killed her Sasha
Loftus spoke with her family tonight
joins us now in studio with more yes
Denise and Brian Shana's family says
they're still trying to wrap their heads
around this one day she was visiting her
friends here in Las Vegas the next she
was gone forever they're hoping someone
will come forward and help them figure
out what happens
she is like way more than just my big
sisters Shauna McCowan a sister mother
and friend stolen far too soon from her
family her sister Autumn shares
everything she loved about her that she
always like had this energy that people
picked up and people wanted to be around
her the 43 year old Colorado woman was
killed in this neighborhood near Dean
Martin and Cactus police say she was
walking with friends around 9pm on April
23rd when someone drove by and shot her
twice Shauna died an hour later at UMC
officers are still searching for a
suspect to have something like this
happen is just
it's kind of mind-boggling this just one
of 42 murders Metro has seen so far this
year higher than at this time in 2022
Autumn hates the thought of Shawna dying
so far from home but she's grateful for
those who helped her I am very thankful
that even though her family couldn't be
with her in those last moments that she
wasn't alone and as they continue to
fight for closure she's asking anyone
with any information to come forward
anything that might help you know
with a case please reach out so they can
find Justice while also doing their best
to remember all the good Shauna brought
to the world I'm Gonna Miss Her
tremendously
now the family has started a GoFundMe to
help with expenses they say they were
able to get shawna's body back to
Colorado she was cremated yesterday if
you have any information on this case
call police or Crime Stoppers Brian